aujourd'hui on va parler d'une image
choisie par claire ce thinel et grâce à
son travail
on va comprendre en quoi une oeuvre peut
être à la fois maladroite et en dire
long sur son époque
[Musique]
aussi mosaïque de près de deux mètres
sur deux qui ornait le sol d'une salle
d'une villa de merida verlan 400 des
personnages sont un peu difficiles à
reconnaître mais cette image montre
ariane découverte par le dieu dionysos
accompagnée de son cortège de s'attirer
de menad sur l'île de naxos où elle a
été abandonnée par thésée après qu'elle
l'ait aidé à sortir du labyrinthe du
minotaure à gauche on reconnaît
difficilement ryan endormi enveloppé
dans un ensemble bizarre peut-être en
tissu tout à droite c'est dionysos il
porte une tunique avec une bande étroite
des sandales tressées et sans le reste
de la composition
on pourrait le confondre avec n'importe
quel habitant d'une ville romaine le
petit diable aux pieds fourchus qui
tient à peine en équilibre c'est un
satyre et à sa droite
c'est une ménade à ses pieds on
reconnaît la panthère qui est une
caractéristique des cortèges dionysiaque
c'est bien la scène classique comme on
la trouve par exemple sur ce splendide
sarcophage du louvre beaucoup
d'historiens d'art à la suite de
l'historien d'art bianchi bandinelli
trouve que cette image représente ce qui
se faisait de pire dans l'antiquité
tardive une parfaite illustration du
déclin de rome et de sa culture
aucune rigueur n'ai aucune discipline
dans le style la tradition antique se
perd claire ce tunnel est assez d'accord
mais elle aime aussi l'étrangeté de la
composition
les personnages ont l'air de flotter
dans un espace à deux dimensions et sont
tous reliés les uns aux autres les mains
ouvertes de la ménade relie dionysos et
le satyre la panthère frôlé une tunique
ou penche la tête devant une robe deux
des personnages sont totalement statique
c'est le cas d'ariane qui se repose dans
son cocon appuyé sur son bras droit et
celui de dionysos il est raide comme une
statue mais son index levé indique peut
être le salut qu'il apporte à ariane et
entre ces deux personnages ça bouge en
regardant bien on peut remarquer que la
ménade cours on le voit sa jambe levée
et au tissu qui volent dans un vent
improbable plusieurs éléments s'ajoutent
aux personnages pour saturer l'espace 6
faire de différentes tailles
un vase peut-être pour le vin apportée
par dionysos un cube entre les jambes du
satyre et une forme étrange au dessus de
la tête du dieu qui pourrait être un
petit soleil noir ou une araignée et
puis il ya la signature de l'auteur anus
fonus fier d'avoir réalisé cette
mosaïque avec cette image claire ce
tunnel ne cherche pas à discuter la
perte de savoir-faire de l'époque en
particulier
disparition flagrante des règles de la
perspective non elle préfère voir ici
l'expression d'une liberté joyeuse
d'ignorer les règles de la composition
et du naturalisme impossible de savoir
si la ménade et le satyre joue à la
balle ou si les sphères sont des
planètes au milieu desquels danse les
promesses des mortalités et c'est
probablement cette incertitude qui donne
à cette oeuvre tout son intérêt
merci à claire ce tunnel pour cette
vidéo qui clôture cette série c'était
une image une histoire
[Musique]